former head of Britain's Armed Forces
says the country needs to rediscover the
mentality that helped to win the Cold
War and deal effectively with emerging
threats like Russia and Iran we asked
people in London what they thought of
that there certainly are tensions
there's no question about tension than
they have in the past I'm not sure I
would go so far as to say it's an you
can't walk any mentality like that is
Russia to walk stairs I really wouldn't
I mean I know some of some of the things
that cause I'm there is you know a pair
but I wouldn't customers the worst if I
questioned what his angle is they
presume this is with regard to pushing
for additional military spending the
remarks come after a report by a London
based think tank which suggests that a
new unit should be created to assess
enemy capabilities while also looking at
the British military's ability to
respond it would be similar to a u.s.
structure that existed in the 1970s at
the height of the Cold War journalist
John White told us he thinks it's all a
diversionary tactic this is rather one
of our British political establishment
that is indeed and unremitting crisis
over the chaos it has rocks over its
mishandling of brexit but more
importantly over the social crisis it
has wrought over its implementation of
austerity over the last year's in
sterner andrew tasks waste of British
taxpayers money at a time as a same so
many people the fifth of the entire
population are suffering grim poverty
and the run-up to Christmas this is a
ruling class that is holding on to the
Past like a drowning man on to a life
raft because that is only half in order
to sustain your position there are
always enemies to be vanquished and
countries to be Schlampe Russia is a
traditional enemy of the British ruling
class but it is by no means the
traditional enemy of the British people
their enemy are the very people who are
telling them that Russia should be their
enemy
you